Кремль погрожує Україні масштабною ескалацією на Донбасі
і натякає на "наслідки для державності", якщо Київ вступить в НАТО.
Цими днями ситуація на українсько-російському кордоні - головна тема
у Брюсселі. Не Росія вирішуватиме - вступати Україні в НАТО чи ні,
наголосили в Альянсі та підтвердили свою непохитну підтримку.
Водночас про конкретні кроки, зокрема надання Україні
Плану дій щодо членства, поки не йдеться.
Коли Україна буде готова до членства у НАТО,
це вирішуватимуть 30 держав-членів НАТО. І ніхто інший
не має жодного права намагатися втрутитися у цей процес.
І це суверенне право кожної держави, такої як Україна,
подати заявку на вступ. І це право 30 країн-членів НАТО
вирішувати, коли пропонувати членство.
Мета візиту до Брюсселя глави українського МЗС Дмитра Кулеби -
обговорити, якою має бути підтримка Альянсу на практиці,
а не лише на словах. За словами міністра, на операційному рівні
Україні необхідні заходи, які стримають Росію
та обмежать її агресивні наміри. І це може бути нова порція санкцій,
яка підвищить ціну російської агресії,
а також пряма підтримка, спрямована на зміцнення
обороноздатності України.
Зібравшись сьогодні, ми намагаємося уникнути помилки,
якої припустилися у 2014 році,
коли Росія була готова діяти блискавично
та переслідувати свої військові цілі у Криму та на Донбасі,
тоді як наші західні партнери обдумували свою реакцію на те, що відбувалося.
Росія не зможе більше нікого заскочити зненацька.
Україна та наші друзі залишаються пильними.
Ми не втрачаємо і не будемо втрачати час.
Якщо Росія вдасться до безрозсудних дій або
почне нову спіраль насильства,
це обійдеться дорого дня неї в усіх сенсах цього слова.
Росія нині намагається відновити сферу впливу і вирішувати,
як діяти її сусідам, стверджує генсек НАТО.
І додає: це той світ, який НАТО намагається залишити позаду,
коли великі держави вирішували, що можна було робити малим сусідам.
Столтенберг закликав Росію негайно припинити нарощування військ
довкола України та зупинити провокації.
Столтенберг - великий майстер говорити дипломатичною мовою,
і за дипломатичними словами він ховає дуже важливі меседжі.
Саме таким ключовим меседжем було, коли Столтенберг
сказав, що країни НАТО і далі допомагатимуть Україні
гарантувати самостійно свою оборону. Що це означає?
Що натівських чобіт, яких так бояться у Росії, не буде на Донбасі.
Навіть якщо і почнеться повномасштабний наступ Росії,
НАТО прямо не втручатиметься у війну. Але що можливо?
Можливим є допомога Збройним силам України
з боку держав НАТО. Допомога озброєнням, додатковими навчаннями,
надсиланням інструкторами. А от в якому вигляді і в якому обсязі буде
надана ця допомога, багато в чому залежить від США.
І саме тому найважливішою зустріччю Кулеби в Брюсселі
є розмова з держсекретарем Ентоні Блінкеном.
Від цієї розмови багато в чому буде залежати і рішення НАТО,
а вирішуватимуть вже у середу на віртуальному засіданні
міністрів оборони і закордонних справ НАТО.
Це засідання екстрене та позачергове, присвячене Україні та Афганістану.
Показовим буде те, що і Блінкен,
і міністр оборони США обидва будуть присутні фізично в Брюсселі.
Росія вже, схоже, готується до можливого відключення
від міжнародних платіжних систем Visa та Mastercard.
За словами голови МЗС Росії Сергія Лаврова,
відбуватиметься поступова дедоларизація російської економіки.
Один з провідних американських спеціалістів щодо відносин з Росією
Метью Рожанскі переконаний: США на чолі з Байденом
будуть набагато жорсткішими, ніж за Трампа.
Було доволі унікально за адміністрації Трампа, що Конгрес
схопив кермо, особливо щодо російської політики, і почав запроваджувати санкції,
тим самим, по суті, зв'язавши руки адміністрації Трампа
і змусивши її оголосити санкції та постійно звітувати про те, що Росія задумала
і так далі. Я думаю, що адміністрація Байдена, по-перше, користується більшою
довірою Конгресу і буде жорсткіше ставитися до Росії.
І, по-друге, таким чином отримає більше простору в діях, більше свободи від Конгресу.
Підхід НАТО - більше інтеграції з Україною за умови
подальших реформ. Але Київ наполягає, що вступ в Альянс -
це не нагорода за правильні реформи, а єдиний спосіб
для України досягнути успіху як держава,
яка може захистити своїх громадян і свою територію.